we're less than two weeks away from the
new xboxes
but if you're an xbox live gold member
who wants to grab some free games on the
current consoles you're in luck
the games with gold lineup for november
has been announced
first up on xbox one is origami shadow
edition
each level sees you teleporting around
in the shadows taking on guards and
collecting scrolls
shadow edition includes the original
game and its dlc
nightfall you can grab origami anytime
in november
as the game will be available to
download all month long
xbox one's other free game is swim
sanity which you can probably guess by
the name is set
underwater the shooter sees you blasting
sea creatures solo or in co-op
and you can compete against other
swimmer shooters and multiplayer too
swim sanity will be available to
download from november 16th
through december 16th now don't tune out
just yet
these 360 games are backwards compatible
for you xbox one players too
the first of these is full spectrum
warrior this rts sees you in command of
fire team's alpha
in bravo sent on a variety of missions
your squads are comprised of leaders
grenadiers and riflemen and you'll have
to give orders to each as you attack and
defend
full spectrum warrior will be available
from november 1st through the 15th
finally the 360 is getting a family
friendly option with lego indiana jones
if you're unfamiliar with the lego
series you take control of all sorts of
characters as you complete levels
solve puzzles and collect studs this
particular one covers the original
indiana jones trilogy
and you can download it from november
16th through the 30th
and those are your free games with gold
for november 2020
remember that you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on gamespot
and stay tuned as we report on the new
games with gold lineup every month
[Music]
you